yeah what happened do you remember what
happened you said you were proof before
all this yeah yeah racist old you last
week remember well what's the story
again no one knows so go be is a great
dog but there are some people that she
doesn't like when people are older
people that are hates wobbly humans if
if so the older person isn't walking
correctly if it's like young children
who are sort of wobbly and unsteady she
freaks out and she barks when she's on
the leash yeah kids yeah hey [ __ ] you
that's my daughter yeah oh yeah sorry
anyway all right all right oh my
goodness that was the dumbest thing I've
ever get about oh my god scratched look
at her did it hurt your animals maybe
I'm a sexy leg just let them come that's
the quickest way you come no let him
come Kiki No can a puppy come racing hey
the dog whatever that would happen yeah
go ahead so what happens if I help me so
remember how I was saying earlier that
like we've kind of we've lost their
minds in this country so divided and
everything is just everyone's just
trying to find something to hurt them
it's just not a good the the vibe is not
generally good yeah and it couldn't have
been more evident than when I was
walking goby and every time I see that
someone approaching I always pick her up
I don't always pick her up but I take
her further away from them just so she
doesn't pop off just so I don't have to
like deal with with judgy people saying
man you know like control your dog or
whatever because I think that shouldn't
like annoys me so if you come into the
entrance of our condo there's a side
entrance and there's a front entrance
right and two guys were coming in so I
left the door open for them as I was
coming out so I was coming out with a
dog I saw that they were coming in so I
use usually a
code to get in our building so instead
of them having to crunch the code I was
like hey they're coming in so I left the
door open
yeah I picked Kobe up and I went away
from them I went the other way to kind
of avoid them and then as they were
opening the door that I had left open
for them these two dudes kept staring at
me like hard and so I kind of stared
back at them like why are they staring
at me like and then I got a little like
defensive cuz I'm like are they gonna
[ __ ] like what are they they look
pissed at me yeah and then the dude came
over like kind of like aggressively and
he was like you had a problem he said
you have a question for me and I was
like what and he was like you're looking
at me like I'm gonna steal something so
you know because in that moment I just
wanna avoid the situation well wait what
now let me guess Lake George that
doesn't ask that's exactly what I was
thinking why are you laughing why are
you laughing okay
so and I was like wait no I was just
trying to take my dog away because she's
kind of an [ __ ] and I just walked
away and I was like hey sorry sorry
sorry cuz I just avoid cuz I'm a [ __ ]
spineless [ __ ] I was like sorry sorry
sorry and I I like walked away it didn't
mean anything by that but i sat there
and I started like really getting pissed
off by the way this [ __ ] just
accused me of being you know basically
being racist when I just left the door
open to the whole building right yeah so
after like thinking on the grass patch
for three minutes I went over there I
went inside the building anyone to go
find them
cuz I couldn't live with myself yeah
yeah this is what this is let me just
say thing right now this is what we're
learning right because we've been
talking about stuff like this where we
regret not speaking up yeah the movie
theater yeah like the movie yeah that so
we're speaking up now kalila and I we
might die one day from from it but we're
not gonna let people walk over us so go
ahead babe bye I didn't even try to find
them to like be confrontational in that
way I just wanted to I was sad about it
and so I went over I knocked on the door
and I was like hey dude
don't come at me like that of all the
people in this building I am the last
person
that person who would profile you I left
the [ __ ] door open for you if I gave
a [ __ ] and I [ __ ] cared if I was
suspicious why did I would leave that
door open for you yeah
and he walked closer and closer and
closer to me and then he realized oh
she's dressed sloppier than me she has
tattoos who she might be just as brown
as me and then he realized that he had
profile from a distance he probably
thought I was just some rich white girl
walking you know outside you know
walking her dog yeah
and I was like I pulled my dog away from
you cuz my dog's an [ __ ] yeah but
eventually he apologized he was like
sorry for the misunderstanding whatever
whatever but I was like it made me feel
so sad that this dude nine out of ten
times he would have been correct nine
out of ten times if someone looked at
him that way
coming into a building especially on
Beachwood here he probably would have
been right and the reason I tell you
he's right is because I have you know
that at the app next door and all my
neighbor's all that you see every day
popping up a notifications suspicious
black man standing outside or suspicious
Latino man standing outside like minding
their own [ __ ] business like this
neighborhood does that so it made me I I
understood where he was coming from that
he felt that he had to confront me about
wrong person can I just say something
though I feel bad after a while yeah but
the thing is is that you know I even me
like when I'm a hatchet sometimes I'm a
haggard and hatchet II ratchet ratchet
yeah I just make up my own like a
hatchet yeah okay yeah a hatchet face is
like yeah that's that's what I am
something I have like sometimes I'll
have like you know when I wake up and I
forget to put the acne medicine I use a
person gel on my face and sometimes I
wake up I forget that you know sometimes
you've seen me wear white on my face and
my hair is all [ __ ] up and I wear
t-shirts with holes in it I've been at
the airport where a white mother will
well if I'm walking she'll she'll bring
the baby or a kid closer to her to
protect her from me
right I don't think to myself what are
you profiling me I think yeah
I would - I'm I look awful I I look
suspicious you know I would do that if
you know if somebody that looked like me
came toward my kid I mean the same thing
happened to me in DC I was at the DC
improv and you know who Bill Cosby is
yeah he's a comedian very funny very
talented it his own show - The Cosby
Show oh it is one of my favorite movies
goes that yeah yeah it's a great movie
right
you knew Barack Obama's anyway so
there's a hot dog place that Bill Cosby
and Barack goes to and I'm walking into
the place but as I'm walking walking
like Emily 20 feet from the door I had
this thought in my head I go where the
[ __ ] my hotel key so I put my hand in
the back of my where my where I put my
hotel key and it was there but as I'm
doing that I'm walking by a black eye
and I swear to God yeah and as I'm doing
that he goes what man you think I'm a
[ __ ] steal and he just let he left
right and I kept mumbling what's up like
that yeah and I never confronted him I
would have no I would never you have
said no dude I was looking for my hotel
key while you were well you you just
happen to be walking by but you want my
money you can have my money look at a
[ __ ] I'm the last person yeah same thing
as you yeah but I told that dude and he
kind of like chuckled but I was like
dude that [ __ ] hurt my feelings it hurt
my feelings when he was like when he
laughed and he was like why would that
hurt your feelings I was like I
basically accused me eraser of seeing
two Mexican guys and then thinking that
you guys were gonna rob my building and
and I told him I was like I don't care
you know if that's funny but that [ __ ]
hurts my feelings and eventually we
squashed it and we had like a good
conversation out of it or whatever but
it just makes me sad that it's come to
that where you know he did he's lived a
life where he feels the need to defend
himself in that way but he's he also
does it maybe so frequently that he
targets the wrong person so I felt
[ __ ] profiles terrific [ __ ] this is
all going awry like this is the problem
with this country
[Music]